hey buddy happening who birdhouse Gomez
on his period of hot welcome back to yet
another episode of Walking Dead Season 2
part episode 3 part 4 3 whatever it's
hard ok it's hot anyway let's keep
playing
we're finding Luke thinks he's behind
the muscular man what do you think I got
blood stain and a counter the blood
stain could be from earlier so let's not
freak out about that it's a bookshelf of
bedding I love betting a cabinet and
blood stain and said oh I love Luke
where is he where the [ __ ] is he why
don't we try
well isn't I swear to Christ you're
gonna regret this oh you ain't supposed
to be out here you ain't [ __ ]
touching Clemmy
I'll [ __ ] dine you people been here
one [ __ ] day and already you're
[ __ ] up well you wait and see what
happens
move Hey just cuz he has a [ __ ] gun
[ __ ] did I [ __ ] up get over
there and how is it that we're repaid
for our trust with treachery wait oh
they found him with theft what's going
on
I don't know Clem I don't like this
whatever you were planning is over
you're done you can't just run from your
problems you can't just up and leave
when it gets tough cuz there's nowhere
else you can go where it ain't tough is
all we got now get that through your
[ __ ] skulls
oh [ __ ]
here he can't help you now you gotta
help yourselves
you gotta help me find the strength to
forgive you then I can start by telling
you where the other one is I'm gonna
count to three if that radio ain't in my
hand by Jesus we'll have to make things
more difficult
I'm gonna confess - I found it it's
right here I got it oh Ken huh
No Ken it's all right
I got Gaby he's always an [ __ ] and
then in the right moment he's a hero and
it makes sure what I was thinking three
Jesus Christ
stop - Clementine hell do you have to do
this bill please bill there's a breach
all right come with me
Bonnie you stick around make sure these
folks don't get into any more trouble
yeah okay no supper for y'all tonight
maybe an empty stomach will give you
some perspective and we'll try this
again tomorrow do your best with him
Carlos you need to get him able to move
because we're leaving tonight even
Bonnie huh even tonight so so now okay
now I trusting
now I can press though okay so maybe if
I had told her dang it I [ __ ] up
I [ __ ] [ __ ] up well it was gonna be
[ __ ] anyway and let's be honest god damn
it
what'd she say she said she can get us
out of the pen if we get the PA system
going second she gives it to run over in
spring us that's great it's not great
what are you talking about
look I know part of this is my fault and
I know I was hungry
I got reckless trying to steal some food
and I got caught I can't stay here look
I hear what you're saying but it's risky
it is pretty damn risky guys risky did
you see what that son of a [ __ ] just
did that the plan works nothing needs to
change
I like Emma's all set up the hard part
is done this guys [ __ ] crazy who
knows we'll do next yeah but now we're
dealing with a guy beat to [ __ ]
Sarita had no shape to do anything and
I'm a goddamn mess look we should rest
up okay we should buy their time and we
should wait for an opening
bodies are greyed to help us tonight and
that doesn't mean she can't do it some
other night I don't know guys Luke's
making sense maybe we should wait no we
should not wait wait no we're now
waiting nothing out there guys trust me
I've looked
there's no food there's no supplies they
picked everything clean I'm just saying
we got to be sensible about this this is
being sensible where's Kenny docks over
there working on it and don't look good
see all right
yeah
why did he ask he was really right there
this is what I'm talking about
can I see him I don't think that's a
good idea
his orbital is crushed I don't think
there's much hope for the eye I got him
as stable as I could
cleaned it got some of the swelling down
bandaged it as best I could but until he
wakes up
we won't know if there's any damage to
the brain since this okay look maybe I'm
just playing devil's advocate here but
if damn it if y'all are serious about
going tonight then we're gonna have to
start talking about maybe leaving some
folks behind no there is no other way
what if this is [ __ ] well I don't
like it either but guess what it's where
were Kenny and I are only here because
of you people and now you would tend to
leave us behind
so we should risk all of our lives what
are you saying nothing I'm just thinking
out loud here Kenny would want us to go
how can you say that after all he's done
for you that's why I know he'd want you
safe he want us all safe
it's what he tell us if he could it it
be something that like that Oh
he's a goddamn pirate
I'm all right huh
we leave tonight plan don't change not
bad old man thanks [ __ ] you are one
tough bastard the tough bastards get
their ass kicked in front of everybody
you all right
that wasn't your fault okay it's alright
damnit again
damnit alright well then what now we get
the hell out of here like now now yes
why are we going that case things get
squirrely and we got to make a break for
it
we need a place to meet up we could read
out of Parker's run the hell is that
it's a civil war site a few miles north
tourist route got signs all over just
follow the road we stopped there after
we escaped the first time Luke and
Carlos know where it is it's not that
far well at least if a few folks know
where it's at
it'll be easier to find if we split up
all right that works then we just need
someone to go set off that PA right I
mean he never bothered to explain who's
supposed to do that yes that's me huh
yeah that's bad I'm damned the girl that
that's all the [ __ ] you [ __ ] wait
wait hold on
she's the plan
let's go bad ass be sure to remember to
flip the switch for the outdoor speakers
hey indoor speakers might not draw the
herd it's right on the microphone box
right by default is set to play music so
you should just have to turn it on right
then climb back up and drop into the
stock room we'll meet you there
[Music]
down into the office outdoor speaker
switch turn on PA up to the roof down
into the stockroom to meet you guys that
right perfect no [ __ ] me I don't
remember a single thing on that
okay we gotta numb and step one down
we're in the stockroom what do we do now
we turn it on the PA
it's the matter with you okay now the
mic all right let's do this
what's wrong [ __ ] there's no tape no
what is this CD receiver
Shh no my god are they oh come on come
on please work
I hope it's relaxed don't annoy all the
zombies they're gonna come for that oh
yeah I love what I get the feeling a lot
of people are gonna die in this episode
I don't like it don't like it one bit
zombies not going crazy over this [ __ ]
Oh snipe they're all gonna come now
[Music]
[Applause]
why don't they all [ __ ] jump behind
run off with this [ __ ] group of
crippled [ __ ] then fine be my guest but
I will put a bullet in you and say it
out a [ __ ] oh yes yes
shoot them in the [ __ ] face I
wouldn't even hesitate [ __ ] that guy
look this ain't none of your business
this is just a bit of a custody battle
we got on our hands here shooter we
should tie him up yeah yeah okay okay we
got any rope or that Mike you just
[ __ ] shoot him [ __ ] yeah I'm glad
that happened I like I don't want it
Clementine to say that we should shoot
him even though I want to shoot him
do you understand like I I I don't know
I don't think it makes sense for Clem to
say that so own it wait outside
we have to go can you please do you
really need a minute go give me you
don't need to see this that girl's
already seen more than you could have
shut your mouth bill do it you're all
just gonna let him do this yes there
ain't one part of that son of a [ __ ] I
don't hate but that does not make this
right
I'm not going anywhere it's gonna get
messy do it now look at you [ __ ]
ingrates
I don't even know how good you got it
that's all right you'll learn lambs to
the slaughter
no Shepard to guide you Clementine knows
exactly what I'm talking about come on
come on Clem
[ __ ] big man huh let's go I think we
should come on Clementine don't be like
that
won't run away you know you want to see
the show who do you think you're fooling
up I know you I know who you are
let's go now go on let the sheep out of
the pen we'll see how long that
I'll be right there you won't see
anything that's funny coming from you
how's that I just follow my voice it'll
get you there
you got a big [ __ ] skull tennis to
put you out of your misery right then
you know I think I made the right choice
by who [ __ ] knows it's not the candy
I know in there I wish save him we don't
have a [ __ ] choice
let's be honest he had to die I'm all
right come on we got enough that's the
Kenny I know all right
we're never gonna make it through this
you kidding me
if Clem could handle it you can no you
little [ __ ] [ __ ] I thought they were
coming from the south they did looks
like we're in the eye of it now
[ __ ] this is getting the guts you're
gonna need someone what happened to the
guts playing come on Clem takes the
first one what the [ __ ] good night
okay now we take the guts you guys
better hurry up and get to smearing if
you want to live I love smearing it's my
favorite you can die here
disgusting yourself its product we act
you Sara I wouldn't put it on my hands
though
okay now you turn around
are you sure I'm sure
there's nothing to fear if you remain
calm I'll keep you safe
hurry the [ __ ] up turn around
I'll get your back it's like some time
it's great Sammy hey man here everybody
ready they're almost on us in the actual
[ __ ] is going on here how we're just
having em is this sick [ __ ] someone say
something before I start hey hey hey
don't you even [ __ ] think about it
[ __ ]
I will and you you hear me Troy Troy we
talked about this what the [ __ ] you're
talking about huh
I told you I wanted to get out you said
you'd help
then I'd help I thought you meant get
out of the pen not whatever the [ __ ]
this [ __ ] is I did it but now we can
leave
Troy you can come with us what
well where would we go away from here
together
well she's mine [ __ ] him man you
smell really bad
that's fantastic
we got this here this Dana line is that
taking
[Music]
Jesus
gonna be okay sexy
yeah shut the [ __ ] out of Italy come
help me
please just say something your friend
she made it
Oh
carefully Karla the 500 Rican it are we
gonna do what I think oh wait oh wait
nothing
do it
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god
that's why I love these games holy [ __ ]
Sarah's glasses oh my god she's gonna
get someone killed
no that [ __ ] voice if I had said I
had the radio
Carver might not have been as as vicious
- don't ever think that darlin huh no
telling what that [ __ ] would have
done to you you look more badass now so
how's it look am I still gonna be pretty
when this heals look like one of em ease
you need to get past that Walker without
drawing all the others what are you
gonna do oh she's gonna be barrel
they're all gonna die Clementine don't
let them pull you down with them damn it
so [ __ ] good
oh god I made the wrong decisions yeah
okay help siren with her chores 67.3%
help sorry I don't know she's such a
little [ __ ] I'm like whatever I'll help
her tell Bonnie about Luke you and there
are only a third said about less than a
third actually to Bonnie
I don't know Bonnie I she really [ __ ]
[ __ ] my trust in the other episode
like I'd really felt like no I don't
want to trust her so that's that's
interesting how that would have changed
things but hey that's how it is that's
what this game is all about admitted to
stealing the walkie-talkie okay well
that was not too hard
watch Kenny kill Carver so it's 50/50 I
don't know I didn't feel that important
to me
Clementine is not a murderer or a crazy
bloodthirst person to me Clementine it's
just [ __ ] Clementine like I don't
think it fits for her to be crazy
chopped off Sarita's arm only six I I
thought for sure everyone would do that
why would you kill the zombie that's not
helping anyone that's interesting anyway
that was a fantastic episode I really
really liked this one these are actually
getting better and better and better so
that's very cool that makes me super
excited for episode 4 & 5 I want to
thank you for us for watching I want to
thank telltale games I want to think
it's like I want something now but
really this games are amazing I really
love them --if and I really appreciated
hear you bros watch it and it helps me
out a lot and you know later like and
all that [ __ ] and for you hit the skyrim
road today they always end with in a
really nice beautiful song but it's
usually copyrighted so I can't
people love it hey what are you gonna do
that's it
sails and breasts love you
[Music]